Film Courage: I get so nervous…
Omari Hardwick: You get nervous?
I thought we [the actors] were the ones who
are supposed to be nervous?
Film Courage: Yeah.
Omari Hardwick: Ground yourself.
Grab onto something.
Film Courage: Good idea.
I will.
Omari Hardwick: There you go.
Film Courage: Omari, for other actors watching
your career right now you are making it look
very easy, which I know you’ve talked about
how it has not been easy for you.
But you’re in SHOT CALLER movie, you’re
on the show POWER and you have all these projects
in the works.
Let’s talk about the hypothetical LA friend
that a lot of us have who is a talented, hard
working actor but they can’t get in a room
because they are not represented by the right
agency.
What’s your advice for that person?
Omari Hardwick: Great way to start an interview,
first of all.
That’s interesting because tonight (for
example) I am inviting friends who got off
the Hollywood Dream Bus with me.
Who never were necessarily able to execute
anything.
You know it’s interesting because they will
be at the screening tonight for this film
[SHOT CALLER with Omari Hardwick as Kutcher]
and it’s one of those things where we don’t
have the same level in common in conversation
as we once had because life has happened for
me differently.
I had to really check in with myself in terms
of the team personality in me thought that
(and I’ve always been a part of sports)
everybody that got off the dream bus with
me and what I mean by that is around the same
month that you get off the Dream Bus and you
come to LA or New York to make things happen
you get a collective of friends and y’all
start to run the audition circuit and slowly
certain people’s pace slows down and others
keep going.
My big thing is always (to the people that
I am inviting tonight and to as you said those
aspiring actors), my wisdom and advice was
always first and foremost, if you can wake
up without wanting to do this…you have one
morning where you wake up and go “Oh…I
don’t really want to do this.”
I would say get out because it’s way too
difficult!
Somebody could ask me are there moments of
that being defined as being discouraged and
I will go No…everybody is discouraged.
Everybody calls home and goes “I don’t
know if I should become a rocket scientist
or as a woman if I should continue in this
world of men and corporate spectrums or law
or medicine or what have you.
People all get discouraged including myself
and asking Mom and Dad if I should come back
home (very early in my journey out here).
But I think in terms of the representation
part I decided to not (and this is really
my wisdom to them) to not really worry about
it.
My thought was it looked like it was easier
for me than it was because I really pressed
hard at the craft, the work, the acting classes,
making sure that I was in martial arts classes
if I could add that to the repertoire box
or the box of tools that I could dig into
if I needed to work on the piano because one
day I could play a character where I play
the piano.
Just work on the craft and don’t necessarily
worry about the representation.
It will find you.
The right agent will find you.
The right manager.
But now am I struggling in terms of wanting
even bigger out of my career while there are
people not where I’m at going “You look
like you made it?”
I don’t know what ‘make it’ is?
I’m satisfied.
I am so humbled and thankful to God that I’m
where I am at but it’s always more and so
if you focus on the more being attained by
making sure that you do more for yourself,
then I don’t necessarily think that the
representation should matter.
Again, I think they definitely will always
find you.
Film Courage: Excellent.
Thank you.
Wow!
Omari Hardwick: Thank you!